it's always humbling because what we see
on our side is just a number
means nothing but when we go to a
convention and we see a room full of
people
and it's it's like putting off like
actual people and faces and interactions
to those numbers it's like
like unless you've experienced that you
can't really describe it you know what i
mean it's
it's very humbling and it's very
flattering and you don't quite
know what the right way to react to it
is so we just hope that we react in a
way that
one doesn't make you feel bad and two
doesn't make us seem like conceited
[ __ ]
you if you know me and you come up to me
you should have like go away from that
interaction thinking damn
yeah it was everything i wanted them to
be yeah that's all i want and it's so
hard because sometimes i'm like do i say
the right thing
should i should i squeeze them a little
harder with the hug should i yeah like
shaking their hand
yeah longer like sometimes like every
time after a convention like
i wake up in a cold sweat to be like man
was i an [ __ ] to that one person
and it's also like you know some people
they always like want a little more and
it's hard because you like
especially if you're going out for like
dinner with your friends it's like oh
man i really don't want them to be like
damn car's an [ __ ] he wouldn't let me
eat with him and it's like well i mean
yeah for some reason i don't give a [ __ ]
about the one hate comment or like the
no
right right oh you see on a youtube
comment but the thoughts of this guy
trashing me to his friends just [ __ ]
keep saying
that keeps me up at night man that's so
real
i could be totally in the right and
being [ __ ] off yeah but i
i i can't do it because i'm like man
this guy respects me so much and i
really don't want to be mean and i'm
trying i'm trying to explain it's so
nice but he's just not getting it
because you know there's a little part
of you where if the roles were reversed
you'd be like man i think it was a
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah which by the way shout
out to that guy i met in akihabara
who i told the story about for being a
good sport about it you know it was it
was an awkward interaction
but uh thank you for being good sports
about it you know i saw your comment and
everything yeah yeah
so yeah i mean yeah bottom line we we
appreciate every single person who comes
up to us it's just that sometimes
every now and then there's just that one
really weird person
just like you know social media just be
you
just just be youthful understand that
social norms do exist in
anime conventions they know that you
know your trash taste
just okay i i think the best way to work
is treat us know differently how you
would just treat a stranger because
you know it's it's how i would explain
like parasocial relationships where
i've i've i've watched people you know
on youtube that
you know you do feel like a connection
with because you feel like you do know
them
but you have to understand that's that
that's a one-way connection you wouldn't
go up to a random stranger and be like
yo bruv i know everything you've done
you know i know your entire life story
let's be friends you know there are
several steps for both ends when it
comes to making friends whether you know
the person or not and
our perspective is we don't know you you
know what i mean so as long as long as
you just
come in with that perspective that that
is the worst question
i i hate i hate it the most like can we
be friends it's the worst question
because this is like so loaded it's like
how on earth
do you expect like me to answer that
like yeah we're best friends here's my
here's my
he's my [ __ ] phone number we're going
on vacation next week right come join me
by the way what's your name
so you don't make friends by asking
someone can we be friends right like i
feel like asking that question you never
win
is the person asking that question
you're never gonna get what you want
yeah and
all you're doing is making the situation
awkward for everyone involved yeah i
have to explain to you be like
um so i don't know you uh i would like
to you know
i'm happy to talk to you and get to know
you later and i hate that talk to
because it makes you sound like an
officer yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't want to because it makes me feel
like i'm like putting them below me
yeah you don't have the right to be
friends you don't have enough subs
it's so difficult because there's no way
of really explaining that without making
it sound like
you're in the better position of like
hey no
no but the the the way i would think
about it is i mean like i said you
wouldn't
ask a person that you whether
or not you've just met can hey can we be
friends
like 90 of the time they're going to be
like uh i mean i don't know you
yeah and you don't know me who are you
can we get to know each other
yeah yeah then we can decide right but
not through
asking that question